Rodney would come in and he was this is
a
he wouldn't go to his own club speaking
of mob he would go coming to catch and
he'd show up in his best rope with a
Heineken and go on stage for 10 15
minutes and he was
so just he was a real comedian like he
hadn't talked to The Comedians and bust
balls I use a lot of them for openers
and you know you could try to sell them
jokes I tried to sell him a few jokes
and he's like all right kid no no no
that's okay you know my jokes was her
shitty and uh and then some you know I'm
trying to tell him like whatever and um
some lady I remember once coming up to
him going Rodney Rodney you don't get no
respect he was okay lady okay go [__]
yourself okay
it's like oh my God
but he was just a he was a funny guy he
was the only real celebrity that would
come in yeah